y concluyeron las audiencias en este
juicio de extradición de julian assange
quien está luchando para no ser
extraditado a eeuu donde de ser
encontrado culpable podría enfrentar una
pena de hasta 175 años de prisión en una
cárcel de máxima seguridad el veredicto
final sobre si assange será o no
extraditado a eeuu lo sabremos en los
próximos meses probablemente el próximo
año mientras tanto la prometida de
julian assange este el amor y salió del
tribunal central
bailey para agradecer a los
simpatizantes de assange el haber estado
apoyándolo durante estas casi cuatro
semanas además advirtió que si assange
es enviado a eeuu sería una violación a
sus derechos humanos y también un
atentado contra la libertad de prensa
además se han unido a esta campaña para
evitar la extradición de assange y eeuu
figuras internacionales como el músico
roger waters y el
político brasileño luiz inácio lula da
silva el día jueves este jueves también
se liberaron decenas de globos blancos
con la leyenda de liberen a assange y
también para celebrar los 14 años de la
fundación de wikileaks